all right my talk on the table is about
a new book that examines racism in
america by speaking directly to black
americans
whose deaths have fueled calls for
change in a long time coming reckoning
with race in america
author michael eric dyson writes letters
to emmett till
eric garner brianna taylor sandra bland
and
others in them dyson explores the need
for police reform
what it means to be a black american and
cancel culture
here are some excerpts from the book
dear sandra bland
i don't know quite how to say this dear
brianna taylor i am outraged
dear eric garner i must say my friend
i can barely begin to understand how we
are back here again
back to a black man begging to breathe
as the cops kill him
as if your death wasn't tragic enough
as if your death hadn't sent so many of
us into the streets
as if your death hadn't already made us
feel utterly endangered
and defenseless in the face of cops who
will never respect us
or treat us like their kin
my fellow americans i beg of you first
consider this do you realize how much
faith it takes for me
and those like me to write my fellow
americans
do you realize how much energy it takes
to summon the will to say those words
do you know that so many black folk are
still full of love for the nation
that so often treats us so poorly we are
used to
hearing presidents say my fellow
americans
my fellow americans my fellow americans
has the sentiment ever really been true
for black folk
do we really live in the same country as
white folk
do we see the same things is our
nation's motto fully realized
e pluribus unum out of many
one and michael eric dyson joins us now
professor dyson thank you for being with
us we can hear from that
reading that's a powerful book i want to
get into the contents of it but i want
to start with its distinctive style
it's written in as a series of letters
to the dead victims of the struggle you
call them
why did you decide to do it that way
well thanks for having me first i didn't
want to write merely about them i didn't
want to further objectify them
i wanted to speak to them you know how
you go visit your loved one
at the gravesite you know they're not
there but they provide you the
opportunity the space to think the
spirit to engage in issue
to reflect calmly to go away from the
maelstrom and say
this is what we must do in order to move
forward so i wanted to write to them to
restore their humanity
to make them feel that in our collective
imagination
that they were present and to give them
the dignity they were denied in life
that's why i chose the epistolary form
to make it more intimate well it works
let's talk about moving forward key to
reckoning
with race in america is reckoning with
police violence against black people in
america
repeatedly on this show however and
other shows police officials have denied
that there is something like systemic
racism or racism at all in the system
so how do you create change when you
don't first have that acknowledgement
yeah it's very difficult to do so the
longer we live
in the 51st state the state of denial as
the late joseph lowry said
we won't be able to engage fully with
the issue and once we put it on the
table once we begin to reckon with the
history of denial
the amnesia that we have willfully
submitted ourselves to
then we'll be able to move forward if
the police could recognize that look
black people call the police more than
any other group
so that means that they are not and typ
you know they're they don't have an
antithesis toward the police and
antipathy for the police
they simply want to be treated fairly
and justly and decently
when the police arrive the police work
for us we don't work for them
they are public servants to protect and
serve
so when we get that on the table when
they begin to treat black citizens
as fully equipped human beings deserving
of their rights
then we can begin to move forward in a
collective bargaining so to speak
with what the future of policing should
look like professor dyson i want to get
your take on canceled culture
number one i did not know that you were
an ordained minister so i was very
surprised to read that i had no idea
yes ma'am you said that your roots stem
from compassion
and when you talk about cancer culture
fortunately or unfortunately i made the
book i think it's page 163 i'm not sure
um i do appreciate your take on that
we're not going to go into that here but
people can read that for themselves but
you talk about cancel culture and you
talk about
the virginia governor northrup and what
was your take on that i thought it was
very interesting because we live in a
canceled culture society big time today
absolutely i didn't you know look i
think the quest for justice is right
i understand the the kind of
disappointment with the criminal justice
system but i don't think the result
and the answer is for us to go around
willy nilly arbitrarily canceling other
people ralph northam is the governor
of virginia when he was a medical
student 20 some odd years ago he dressed
in black face was it wrong of course was
it ridiculous yes
was it nefarious in some instances of
course but
my point was don't cancel him out
nothing better than a white public
official
who is conscious of the fact that he
owes black people his future because
they stand with him
regardless of his mistake i'm a baptist
preacher 41 years
i believe in forgiveness should we hold
people to account absolutely
should they when they mess up should
they fess up yes but then we should
dress up we should address the issue
and move forward what has he done since
then he has done so many programs
including
uh the 10 000 uh ex-felons who have now
been restored
in terms of their rights a
disproportionate number of whom are
african-american and when i think about
morgan whalen down in
tennessee did he do something wrong by
using the n word absolutely was he
speaking to black people no
but he knows he was wrong he even
released a video saying don't defend me
i like the fact that he has taken
responsibility for his actions
however let's not let him lose his uh
contract
let's not cancel him altogether allow
him to be restored restorative justice
says
somebody does something wrong we hold
them to account and then we put them
back into society
to allow them to flourish i don't think
canceling somebody is absolutely the way
it's white supremacy as i argue in the
book
on the sly that's the impulse to cancel
somebody
absolute intolerance professor i know
we're short on time we have to go but
something stood out in your book where
you said millennials see race
the same as baby boomers i was very
surprised by that what do you mean
yeah well pew studies did a report that
said aside from
interracial relationships millennials
see race pretty much the same way that
boomers did
which means it's not an automatic
progress dr king said there's not
we don't roll in on the wheels of
inevitability you have to make a
conscious decision
to make a difference i was heartened by
the fact that after george floyd's death
uh hundreds of thousands of white
brothers and sisters joined black and
brown and red and yellow people in this
country
to make a difference that's what we have
to do a conscious decision
to make a difference and when they when
they get involved then they start to see
things differently i thought that was a
very important point
absolutely professor pastor dyson
learned something in the book today
thank you very much for joining us
really appreciate it
the name of the book is called long time
coming it's on sale now wherever you
like to buy your book